Social Security is running out of money
but don't worry our presidents always
say they will strengthen and save Social
Security safeguard Social Security I'll
save Social Security except
unfortunately none will really save it
here's the problem
years ago government made us a promise
Social Security is a program you can
count on now and in the future even if
you don't save for your retirement
government will save for you we are with
you through life's journey
Social Security securing today and
tomorrow but the program doesn't secure
tomorrow the politicians mislead us they
didn't save your Social Security
payments they spent every penny the
moment they came in but most people
don't know that what happens to that
money well hopefully it's held in trust
actually they spent it so what's there
gonna be for me when politicians began
old-age programs they assumed there'd be
enough young workers to tax to cover the
costs of sending checks to old people
people like me but people like we are
living longer these days so there aren't
enough young people to pay for us as a
result Social Security's going broke
this year it went into the red for the
first time there is a plan out there to
save it but it requires some tough
choices the Heritage Foundation proposes
cutting payments to rich people and
raising the retirement age to 70 there
are some common-sense tweaks that we can
make sense to you you're young well you
thought what happened is that when
Social Security actually was founded
life expectancy was below 65 the purpose
of the program was to protect those few
lucky ones that outlived everybody else
or today the vast majority lived past 65
Social Security now has a 32 trillion
dollar shortfall you expect to collect
Social Security from the government no I
doubt it
I suppose it's progress that this was
the first time talking to people on the
street when most people understood the
problem it's just a question of how much
money we're gonna print
or borrow I mean we're already at a
trillion dollars a year Social Security
is kind of like the Titanic a ship
heading for an iceberg this is a massive
ship that moves very slowly if we start
making reforms now we can avoid the
iceberg if we wait until we can see the
iceberg right in front of our noses and
then we try to turn the ship we're gonna
run right into it
Medicare will hit its iceberg in just
eight years then benefits will
automatically be cut Social Security
will hit it in 15 years what's to be
done the Democrats say spend even more
you don't cut Social Security you expand
it nearly every Democrat in the United
States Senate has voted in favor of
expanding Social Security human wants
and needs are unlimited there's always
another need another program that needs
more funding and pay for it by taxing
rich people that's part of my commitment
to raise taxes on the wealthy just tax
the rich there isn't enough money even
that the rich would have to pay for the
two hundred trillion and unfunded
liabilities that we already have on the
books so we're young people worried do
you ever think about Social Security
I actually don't and still I still feel
like I'm too young to know about it when
you're old how are you gonna support
yourself I have no idea it's a failed
system really because it's it's almost
like a big Ponzi scheme one partial
solution proposed by heritage and others
is to let workers put some of their
Social Security money into personal
retirement accounts just imagine being
able to own and control your own
retirement dollars they could invested
in businesses that could grow the
economy whatever rocks your boat private
accounts would almost certainly pay you
more than Social Security even a
conservative portfolio of stocks and
bonds that got you about a 5% annual
return umut would make many times more
private accounts have been tried in a
few countries the investment they
created helped Chile
rise from one of the poorest countries
in Latin America
erricka to the richest and yet private
accounts are still a hard sell even in
Chile left to subject capitalist getting
a cut of you demonstrators are calling
an end to the management of pensions by
private financial institutions we lack
gratitude for what the free market
provides that is difficult to wrap your
head around it's easy to think oh here
is the government this is where I go to
private accounts are also unpopular in
America we will never let the
Republicans cut or privatize Social
Security what you guys are pushing is
the right thing to do but it's not
popular it is not popular but I think
people don't fully understand how these
programs work what happens for that
money goes into a pool I guess you know
they actually don't keep it in the trust
fund they spend it right away didn't
know that when I get my paycheck a lot
of it goes to taxes and I see the Social
Security part of it and it's like $30 of
my whole paycheck you would rather keep
that 30 bucks and put it into your own
savings account yeah I would the country
is in a deficit there's a point where
you can't pay out and go in the negative
forever she's right
far better to fix old age programs now
rather than have them suddenly go
bankrupt later